Isabel y musa miran las fotos del
nacimiento de sus dos hijos
durante 11 años la pareja intentó
concebir un bebé de manera natural pero
no tuvieron éxito es difícil saber
cuántas parejas se ven afectadas por
este problema en un informe publicado
recientemente por la OMS se estima que
la infertilidad afecta al 13% de los
adultos en África pero son pocos los
estudios sobre el tema fue muy doloroso
porque mi marido y yo nos amamos
pero en África una mujer tiene que tener
hijos para tener un hogar
sin hijos no hay hogar
no importa cuánto amor haya entre tu
marido y tú yo sufrí mucho por eso
vivíamos con su familia en el barrio los
jóvenes ya tenían hijos pero nosotros
dos no teníamos siempre nos criticaban
sus dos hijos fueron concebidos mediante
fecundación in vitro
la pareja invirtió todos sus ahorros en
la reproducción asistida
Mis hijos no tienen precio Aunque haya
gastado millones de francos eso ya quedó
atrás ni siquiera recuerdo cuánto gasté
mis bebés están conmigo me dicen mamá
regresan de la escuela y dicen mamá papá
acudieron a la única clínica de Costa de
Marfil que ofrece a las parejas
estériles la posibilidad de recurrir a
la reproducción asistida aquí dos veces
por semana los cirujanos realizan la
extracción de óvulos un paso crucial en
los tratamientos de fecundación in vitro
vamos a extraer todos los ovocitos para
inseminarlos con el esperma del cónyuge
todo esto será implantado en la cavidad
uterina para lograr un embarazo
[Música]
César la clínica recibe solicitudes de
toda África
el primer año atendimos a 39 parejas hoy
atendemos a quinientas el objetivo de
este año es aumentar esa
cifranean Corpus hay que entender que la
infertilidad es ahora un problema de
salud pública y afecta cada vez más a
las parejas
antes eran más las mujeres las que
venían por insuficiencias ováricas
anomalías en las trompas de falopio pero
ahora cada vez son más los hombres
quienes presentan anomalías en su
esperma
la reproducción asistida es costosa
cada intento cuesta entre 1500 y 5000
euros una suma muy alta en un país donde
el salario promedio es de 115 euros
mensuales
otras mujeres recurren a métodos más
tradicionales es el caso de Lucy madre
de una joven que no logra quedar
embarazada
Lucy conoció a michelín conocida como
mamá testimonio por el boca a boca
acudió a ella para tratar los miomas
uterinos de su hija ni siquiera ir al
hospital funcionó
es caro allá
con todas las facturas que tengo que
pagar No puedo permitirme grandes gastos
médicos
con un doctor tradicional solo pago el
equivalente a unos 10 euros para ayudar
a mi hija a quedar embarazada
desde 2005 mamá testimonio se
autodenomina curadora de la infertilidad
en hombres y mujeres en su consultorio
almacena cortezas plantas y hojas que
recolectan en su pueblo
Esto es para tratar fibromas quistes y
miomas te lo tomas para lavar tu
interior y la enfermedad sale de tu
cuerpo
si se para si es para quedar embarazada
el embarazo vendrá
estarás liberada
hombres que tienen debilidad impotencia
eyaculación precoz problemas de próstata
curo todo tipo de enfermedades
los remedios tradicionales cuya eficacia
no está demostrada sucitan más interés
que la medicina moderna según este
sociólogo estos incluso son el origen de
ciertos problemas de fertilidad en
África la prevalencia de ciertas
enfermedades como las infecciones de
transmisión sexual es muy frecuente
entre los jóvenes
pero no reciben un tratamiento médico
adecuado
una de las consecuencias a largo plazo
es la infertilidad
esto podría explicar porque las parejas
tienen problemas para concebir el doctor
yao considera que el impacto psicológico
causado por la infertilidad afecta más a
las mujeres en primer lugar para las
mujeres hay una presión psicológica
porque sienten que la culpa es de ellas
muy a menudo los hombres en africa no se
dan cuenta de que no pueden procrear Así
que las mujeres buscan una solución
pueden tener relaciones extramaritales
para quedar embarazadas
entonces cargan con el peso de esta
culpa porque quieren salvar el honor de
su familia muchos expertos consideran
que hacen falta políticas públicas que
sensibilicen sobre los problemas de
infertilidad Pero también es necesario
que los costos bajen y que el acceso a
los procedimientos sea más fácil